si le premier ministre justin trudeau
dit qu'il ne veut pas d'une élection cet
automne
ces actions envoie un message différent
à preuve un arrêt de style campagne
électorale à l'usiné 3m de brockville en
ontario
l'usiné fabriquera et livrera chaque
année 25 millions de masques n95 au
gouvernement fédéral et 25 millions à la
province de l'ontario
ottawa veut ainsi remédier à la pénurie
de masques qui menaçait le pays en début
de pandémie
on veut aussi s'assurer d'avoir démasqué
n95 à notre disposition
si jamais on est confronté à une autre
crise de santé publique dans les années
à venir
à ses côtés un allié est probable il y a
tout juste un an lors de la dernière
campagne électorale
donc faut il était une cible de choix
pour justin trudeau
le premier ministre conservateur qui
dirige une province clé félicite
aujourd'hui son homologue fédéral justin
trudeau a fait un travail incroyable
durant cette pandémie lance-t-il il est
à l'écouté et notre collaboration est
excellente mais le sujet qui talonne le
premier ministre trudeau
c'est la prorogation du parlement qui
risque de compromettre l'adoption de la
réforme de l'assurance emploi et des
nouvelles prestations de relance
économique lié l'aco vide
je peux être très très clair que riez
liés à la preuve agacé prorogation à
voir ralentir notre capacité de
continuer d'être là pour les canadiens
du même souffle le premier ministre met
au défi les partis d'opposition de voter
contre cette aide 37 milliards de
dollars que les libéraux minoritaires
s'apprête à distribuer au travail à je
pense que les canadiens peuvent avoir
confiance que la préoccupation première
de ce gouvernement et j'espère des
autres partis c'est au jour le bien-être
des canadiens
c'est une menace à peine voilée que
serge justin trudeau au parti
d'opposition le premier ministre mise
sur sa gestion crise en temps de
pandémie pour faire oublier la sphère
unis et pour convaincre ses adversaires
et les canadiens qu'il a le gros bout du
bâton
si christian noël radio canada ottawa